Noah's a fantastic professor and the
fact that he grew up as a deaf
individual he's very connected to the
deaf culture and the community so some
of the nuances that may not be apparent
when you're getting taught by hearing
professor Noah covers
everything and the way he conveys his
emotions and his thoughts through is
signing it's really apparent that he's
definitely really passionate about what
he's doing and you can really get
that from all of his lectures it has
just taught me that individuals who may
have different experiences or different
backgrounds like aren't necessarily hard
to interact with like I've had so much
fun with Noah as a professor I remember
my first precept the reason why I stuck
with it was because I actually like made
him laugh at like my inability to sign
something he showed us the sign for sad
which was like this and he was like what
do you think this sign for happy is and
I was like and he's like no that's the
sign for humiliated and like there's no
errors here and like we're all on the
same level and we're all just trying to
learn to communicate with each other I'm
interested in practicing clinical
neuropsychology and being able to
communicate with the families and the
parents of the children is actually a
really good skill to house the
importance of actually just
understanding this other culture is
something that I came across in this
class and not even that just being able
to communicate well with others
is a key concept in ASL so you have not
only the sign but your soft facial
expressions that play a key role in the
grammar structure of ASL so just being
able to communicate really well I think
is a great takeaway that I've had from
this class